[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette émission spéciale
de dimanche en politique ici au café de
la poste de velars sur ouche en côte
d'or pour une émission d'une heure en
direct et en public à moins de deux ans
des élections municipales les défections
de mer n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses
plus de mille élus ont rendu leurs
écharpes depuis 2014
la colère gronde notamment dans les
petites communes les maires non plus la
foi alors d'où vient cette hémorragie
nos petites communes ont-elles malgré
tout un avenir nos territoires ruraux
sont ils les oubliés de la république
on en débat ce dimanche matin dans un
instant je vous présenterai nos invités
mais nous ne serons pas seuls des
témoins des militants des personnes
concernées par ce débat sont avec vous
elle a besoin bonjour bonjour jean
christophe bonjour à tous effectivement
ils vont pouvoir suivre les échanges le
débat devant un écran à mes côtés des
maires ruraux qui nous feront part ou
non de leur sentiment d'impuissance à
mes côtés aussi des citoyens des acteurs
de la vie publique à qui nous
demanderons s'il se sentent délaissés
par l'état par les politiques des grands
témoins qu'on a voulu réunir ici pour un
grand débat citoyen c'est une nouveauté
sur france 3 bourgogne on viendra les
voir tout au long de l'émission pour les
faire réagir et ils vont pouvoir à leur
tour interrogé voir interpeller vos
invités jean christophe à tout à l'heure
merci est là on vous retrouve donc dans
un instant pour les premières réactions
et prise de parole autour de vous et
puis vous qui nous regarde et vous
pouvez bien sûr commenter cette émission
avec le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne
alors nos invités qui ont accepté de
débattre ce dimanche matin en direct
yolaine de courson bonjour vous êtes dit
oui prenez tous un micro vous êtes
député la république en marche de
côte-d'or merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes une ancienne maire dont vous nous
parlerait aussi de cette réalité là
patrice joly bonjour bonjour sénateur
socialiste de la nièvre président de
l'association nationale nouvelle
ruralité comme sénateur évidemment vous
êtes au contact vous aussi des élus
locaux au quotidien jean-françois farenc
bonjour
vous êtes maire sans étiquette de blanot
franche saône-et-loire président des
maires ruraux de saône-et-loire merci
également d'être avec nous et puis louis
gentilhomme bonjour quand je ancien
maire vous aussi sans étiquette c'est
souvent le cas d'ailleurs dans les
petites communes on en parlera peut-être
de saint seine sur vingeanne cet
encodeur et vous avez démissionné en
janvier dernier vous nous direz pourquoi
dans quelques minutes
alors jean-françois farenc j'ai envie de
m'adresser à vous au début de cette
émission vous qui êtes président des
maires ruraux de saône-et-loire réplique
est maire d'une commune
vous avez entendu un le portrait que
j'ai dressé aujourd'hui delà de la
situation tous ces maires qui jette
l'épongé
toutes ces difficultés qui s'accumulent
et finalement beaucoup plus de démission
de mr que par le passé est ce que vous
faites le même constat vous dans votre
département
oui exactement nous faisons le même
constat lors on a même compté 1 il ya eu
17 en saône et loire 17 maires qui bat
qui ne sont qu était maire en 2014 qui
ne sont aps le maire aujourd'hui
bon il y a quatre ou cinq décès 1 sur
les sur les 17 mai le reste ce sont des
gens qui effectivement ont décidé de
lâcher leur mandat est bon quand vous
les écoutez c'est une une somme de
raison c'est une somme de raison
je vais en citer deux autres rapidement
l'intercommunalité est quand même un la
manière dont l'intercommunalité est
exercée est souvent un souci parce que
les mères ont l'impression de simplement
d'assister que les décisions sont prises
en amont et de regarder passer les
trains ça c'est un premier sujet
l'empilement des normes est aussi est
aussi un vrai sujet et puis le transfert
de compétences les transferts de
compétences automatique et on en a eu
malheureusement eu encore un exemple
l'été dernier c'est quelque chose qui
est très très mal vécue par les
transferts aux assainissements le
l'assemblée a décidé malgré l'avis du
sénat malgré l'avis unanime du sénat
l'assemblée nationale a décidé de
transférer automatiquement cette
compétence communautaire communauté de
communes s'est très mal vécu certains
sont prêts à ce que c'est que compétents
soient transférés et pourrait en décider
ainsi mais quand c'est fait de manière
automatique caen s'est imposé moi c'est
quelque chose qui vient qui
décrédibilise un peu plus le
l'intercommunalité
on va écouter yolaine de courson qui est
forcément autour de cette table
représente aussi la la majorité en place
yolaine de courson vous comprenez et
vous avez la même analyse de la
situation des ces maires des petites
communes dont vous avez été un logis
bien je comprends très bien ce que dit
monsieur chirac
je comprends qu'ils aient des maires
qu'ils soient fatigués épuisés mais par
ailleurs je ne partage pas complètement
son point de vue forcément il ya des
bars effectivement qui ont fait beaucoup
de vendeurs aussi
donc quand on a fait beaucoup de mandats
après on s'use il ya aussi
le monde change les citoyens change et
effectivement il ya eu la loi nôtre qui
est passé par là pour parler de ce que
dit le sieur un gouvernement mais bon
donc c'est passé par là et effectivement
il ya eu des transferts de compétences
mais pourquoi il ya des transferts de
compétences à une communauté de communes
n'ont normalement les communautés de
communes sincère avoir des projets
ensemble et à pouvoir investir ensemble
pour arriver à faire ça c'est les choses
en fait c'est à dire les facilités
certaines choses et à dire que bon
effectivement à l'eau et
l'assainissement
ce gouvernement n'a pas imposé et au
contraire il a laissé un délai jusqu'à
2026 pour que les communes s'organisent
il faut savoir que l'eau et
l'assainissement
c'est un problème dans notre pays sur la
qualité de l'eau par exemple chez moi
dans châtillonnais faut savoir que la
qualité de l'eau des pas bonne il faut
savoir aussi que 25 % de l'eau dans
l'est dans les réseaux fui donc l'eau
est un bien commun alors c'est 20 cas
des communes où l'eau coûte 50 centimes
le mètre cube vous rendez compte
comment peut-on faire les travaux de
réhabilitation en revanche je pense
qu'il faut en parler parce
qu'effectivement il ya des communes qui
gèrent très bien l'euro 1 alors après
jusqu'en 2026 il ya moyen d'en parler et
de voir comment il peut y avoir des
partenariats ou des des syndicats parce
que ça peut aussi ceux gérés par des
syndicats de l'eau ah c'est pas obligé
que ça parte communauté comme il ya
plusieurs formules eia jusqu'en 2026
pour s'en occuper
donc le fait que les verts soient est
fatigué je comprends pas ce que le les
grands maires de petites communes c'est
vraiment un des mandats les plus
difficiles ce code est vraiment apporté
de bafin commente le quotidien des
citoyens et c'est ça qui est quand même
passionnant non plus alors on va
rejoindre elle a besoin qui est juste à
côté de nous parce que il ya déjà des
réactions vous êtes avec un élu elsa oui
peut-être un contre-exemple jacky vous
vous êtes le maire de cette petite
commune de velars sur ouche ce sentiment
d'usure convient d'évoquer ce que vous
l'avez déjà ressenti vous ah oui je le
partage tout à fait ce qui vient d'être
dit par monsieur farenc
je le partage totalement car en effet il
ya un certain nombre d'éléments qui font
qu'aujourd'hui les maires sont un peu
fatigués quelles sont nos difficultés
les difficultés se sont déjà les baisses
de dotations quand on sait qu'une
commune tels que villard sur 174 mille
de jeff a perdu 35% en l'espace de cinq
ans c'est quand même énorme ça fait 61
mille euros de moins pour faire des
investissements
alors justement c'est cette équation
c'est faire au mieux avec moins vous
renier sur quoi vous en tant que mère
m'a écoutée sur le fonctionnement on
essaye de fonctionner au mieux
nous avons déjà on n'a pas remplacé à un
agent des services techniques
bon on est obligé de calculer au jour le
jour à flux tendu est ce que vous avez
déjà songez-vous à rendre votre écharpe
non parce que vis-à-vis des habitants je
considère qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
mais il ya des tas d'éléments il ya
l'usure les normes également la lourdeur
administrative la lourdeur
administrative avec la dématérialisation
ou les âges en il ne s'y retrouvent plus
et par manque de formation aussi est ce
qu'il ya des jours où vous vous dites
des moments où vous dites je ne peux pas
satisfaire mes administrés
c'est vrai oui oui il ya des jours on
s'est dit on ne peut pas réparer des
routes on ne peut pas apporter ce que
les habitants attendent
et ça on en est
désolé vous allez vous représentez non
non mais bon là j'ai dans la j'avais
décidé bien avant l'heure présente
ils sont presque à beaucoup sur presque
plus de plus de 50% à ne pas se
représenter certainement un d'après
d'après les dernières études beaucoup
plus nombreux que par le passé patrice
joly on a entendu les baisses de
dotations à je me retourne vers vous le
sénateur socialiste parce que ça fait un
moment que ça dure les baisses de
dotations aux communes et aux
collectivités locales ça ne s'arrête pas
mais votre majorité avoue celle de
françois hollande avait déjà commencé ce
mouvement comment vous expliquer aux
maires que on peut trouver d'autres
solutions pour financer parce que ils
ont l'air d'être un peu d'avoir serré la
ceinture très largement et de plus
pouvoir répondre aux attentes de leurs
administrés c'est une réalité les
tensions financières sont réels les
marges de manoeuvre se réduisent vous
avez évoqué les dotations mais il ya
également les contrats aidés qui était
une source importante de moyens
supplémentaires accordés accordées aux
communes qui permettait de d'apporter
des réponses à d'assur un certain nombre
de services
derrière ça mais je ne partagerais déjà
cette critique dans l'ancien sur
l'ancien gouvernement
ça renvoie la notion de la gestion de la
dette publique aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui la question de la dette
publique elle est aussi fonction des
moyens qu'on se donne pour leur
rembourser et par le on est depuis
maintenant une vingtaine d'années dans
un dans une logique politique qui vise à
réduire la part du secteur public et
donc à part des dépenses publiques on
peut se poser la question si c'est une
bonne solution pour répondre aux
problèmes de l'eau territoires ruraux en
particulier qu'ont besoin d'intervention
publique de services publics
d'équipements publics peut-être plus que
d'autres territoires parce qu'il ya des
capacités d'initiative privée je pense
en particulier dans l'est dans les
métropoles
aujourd'hui donc les maires aussi au
delà de ses marges de manoeuvre qui se
réduisent donc des perspectives d'action
qui diminue les libéraux ont le même
état d'âme que l'ensemble de la
population de l'eau territoire dire le
sentiment de ne pas être reconnu pour ce
que nous valons et pour ce que nous
pouvons offrir également à l'état on a
quand même le sentiment pas simplement
sous ce gouvernement mais depuis 10-15
peut-être même 20 ans on a le sentiment
que l'avenir de la france dépensait
qu'autour des la perspective est de
l'avenir d'aidé
métropole et si l'avenir et c'est
vraiment dommage parce que nous avons
beaucoup à offrir un autre pays en
matière de développement et de
redressement et jean françois parent que
cette baisse des dotations avec aussi
cette incertitude de beaucoup de maires
sur la question de la suppression la
taxe d'habitation qui devrait d'après le
gouvernement je parle sous le contrôle
de courson mais devrait être compensé à
l'euro près il n'empêche que beaucoup de
maires s'inquiètent
cette baisse des dotations est là elle a
quand même un effet important
un maire pourquoi un maire s'engage il
s'engage il sait qu'il va avoir de la
gestion à faire de la gestion courante
de l'entretien de sa commune de
l'entretien de voirie et puis il a aussi
dans l'idée en général avec son équipe
de conduire des projets et pour conduire
des projets il faut des ressources
financières il faut un autofinancement
il ya les subventions mais il faut un
autofinancement et l'effet de cette
baisse des dotations c'est que les que
beaucoup de communes ont n'ont plus de
ressources de pour financer leur projet
pour mettre les 20% qui sont toujours
nécessaires quand on construit un projet
bon si on se débrouille bien on peut
avoir 70 à 80 % de subventions
c'est assez rare 87 assez rare
aujourd'hui mais 70 mais il faut que la
commune met 30
et aujourd'hui si vous avez un budget
avec la les baisses de dotations de
fonctionnement vous n'avez plus donc les
maires se trouve depuis sont plus en
situation de construire des projets par
contre ils ont toujours le quotidien
l'ailé les démarches des citoyens sur le
quotidien donc
donc c'est quelque chose qui est qui
contribuent à la halle à la fatigue dont
on parle ce qui les blesse qui les
fatigues
c'est justement aussi qu'ils ne peuvent
pas assumer finalement leur programme le
programme électoral pour lequel ils ont
été élus vous le dise oui tout à fait
alors les maires effectivement d'être de
notre association notre association nous
avons 240 mère qui sont à l'association
des maires ruraux en saône-et-loire et
nous le disent ils nous le disent ils
ont pas et ils avaient ils avaient prévu
ça peut être de rénover un bâtiment de
te faire des investissements pour
l'école et ils ont plus les moyens de
de faire ces projets où il les dit faire
il les dit faire il les dit faire
maintenant beaucoup me disent avant on
pouvait mener deux projets aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus emmener qu'un donc ça
c'est très bien réagir et à entrer en
dialogue avec vous avec elle a besoin
qui est à nouveau à côté de gens qui
souhaitent réagir ici dans ce café de la
poste de velars sur ouche souris avec
gérard vous avez vous été élu pendant
très longtemps
vous m'avez interpellé vous aviez
quelque chose à dire oui à propos de
l'eau et de l'assainissement
j'ai un exemple très concret le
gouvernement a voté cette année une
diminution du permis de chasse qui passe
de 400 euros à 200 euros divisé par deux
voilà et personne ne s'est posé la
question de qui allait financer cette
différence la différence elle sera
financée par le consommateur d'eau
puisque l'état inscrit dans son budget
un préleveur et un prélèvement de 480
millions d'euros sur les agences de
l'eau et notamment au profit de la
biodiversité et de law and say hello ncc
39 millions d'euros alors louis
gentilhomme et n'est plus maire mais il
est président du syndicat des eaux
avec une particularité c'est que notre
eau arrive de haute marne
donc on a affaire à deux 2 comment deux
préfectures pour gérer notre
problématique de l'eau et jusqu'à
présent pour faire ces travaux puisque
le réseau qui alimente mille abonnés
fait 60 km donc pour rénover ce réseau
qui a une soixantaine d'années il ne
peut pas le faire sans subvention et
cessent les choses ont changé depuis
l'arrivée d'emmanuel macro pouvoir en
pire oui puisque le on nous a supprimé
les agences de l'eau comme elles
financent ce
ces prélèvements enfin qu'elle doive
fines elles sont taxées par ce
prélèvement non plus les moyens de
subventionner les travaux
d'assainissement et sur les réseaux
d'eau gérard vous vous avez jeté
l'épongé en tant qu'adjoint pour quelles
raisons tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit
quand on prépare l émission j'en avais
ras le bol
l'usure le fait de ne pas être compris
entendus
on nous écoute ne nous entend pas et on
est beaucoup trop faible pour faire
changer les choses
ça dure depuis des années où ses récents
non j'ai toujours connu ça en 19 ans de
mandat ç'a toujours été comme ça et on
nous on nous écoute poliment mais on
nous ignore
il ya du mépris il ya de la
condescendance
donc c'est assez difficile au bout de
plusieurs années de supporter cet état
qu'est ce que vous allez demander à
yolaine de courson la république en
marche vous avez une question pour elle
alors j'ai deux questions alors faire en
sorte que les les présidents de syndicat
d'eau puissent continuer à effectuer les
travaux et au sujet du prélèvement qui
est fait aux communes sur le au profit
du fonds national de garantie
individuelle de ressources qui
garantissent aux communes qui on perde
était perdante avec la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle que ce fnb hier
soit remis comme il avait été prévu par
la commission des finances chargé
d'étudier ce dossier une durée de vingt
années au lieu de financer advitam
eternam une un fonds qui bénéficie qui
bénéficie aux plus gros elle a une envie
de transparence si je résume vos progrès
par exemple la commune de saint seine
sur vingeanne ses 30000 euros par an que
l'on donne à ce fonds dont caen 8 en a
déjà donné 240 mille euros voilà merci
alors si lien à des questions très
techniques dans lequel on peut peut-être
pas rentrer là mais tout à l'heure on
prendra un café avec hélène de course
pour en savoir plus mais d'un mot
condescendance pas mépris mais pas loin
et puis vraie difficulté avec 15 bat
depuis que c'était manuel macro pouvoir
c'est encore pire j'ai entendu un oui
mais elle a dit que depuis 19 ans
c'était pire bon voilà je suis
exactement dans la dynamique inverse je
pense que on peut vraiment aller vers du
mieux
je suis pas du tout pour la ruralité
gémissante mais pour la réalité
conquérante je pense que je partage avec
mon collègue joli nom là il faut arrêter
avec cette histoire de baisse des
dotations ya eu des baisses de dotations
2014 de vikash demi sel mais ces baisses
de dotations pour les communes rurales
sont arrêtés vous êtes tous les emplois
aidés qui vont et qui sont diminués et
qui vont aller en s'affaiblissant
d'ailleurs vous non pas du tout je peux
pas vous laisser dire ça il y aurait 200
mille contrats aidés d'ailleurs vous
faisait partie des rares députés à
l'héroïne qui était pas vraiment
d'accord pour la fin des employés des
eaux sans ça moi je suis pour que les a
pas aidés débouche sur un vrai emploi ce
qui n'est pas le cas il ya que 20 % des
contrats aidés qui donne lieu à des
véritables emplois donc les gens ils
restent dans un espèce de là même qui
sont dans les contrats aidés ne veulent
plus en être
donc aujourd'hui ces contrats aidés vont
être remplacés par les parcours en pl
compétences qui sont les personnes qui
emploient ces gens là on va être obligé
les accompagner dans la formation est
vraiment pour un débouché vers un emploi
donc ça c'est beaucoup plus important
puisque mais aujourd'hui il ya quarante
mille de ses forts courants par
compétences qui ne sont pas encore
utilisés parce que c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué de former des
gens de les accompagner vers un vrai
emploi que de prendre des contrats aidés
qui en fait sont des espèces de 100
places subventionnées par tout le monde
voyait ainsi qu'un service dans les
petites communes et vous en savez quand
j'en ai encore un petit peu
jean-françois farenc sur les emplois
aidés c'est une des difficultés
aujourd'hui oui
donc il y avait il y avait effectivement
des emplois qui étaient dans l'air dans
les écoles dans les mêmes temps parfois
parfois dans l'entretien est alors
effectivement vous dites 20% simplement
arriver à transiter vers un vrai emploi
mais vous avez dans la société il faut
aussi admettre de lier à reconnaître que
dans la société
vous avez des vous avez un certain
nombre de personnes parce qu'ils n'ont
pas tous les peut-être tous les atouts
qui auront beaucoup de mal à des
arrivées sur un et obtenir un emploi
normal et je pense que ces gens là ont
droit aussi à l'emploi donc il faut les
il faut les prendre en compte et
l'emploi aidé c'était c'était remettre
sur le train du travail sur le chemin du
travail un certain nombre de personnes
qui on peut avoir un certain nombre de
difficultés qui auraient des difficultés
sur un emploi normal sur un emploi
standard il y avait une situation
d'insertion une réaction de patrice joly
sur deux sur la question des employés
voulu réagir et puis ensuite on passera
aux lourdeurs administratives avec louis
gentilhomme qui en sait quelque chose
un aspect humain concernant les emplois
aidés qu'il faut avoir en tête à dire
que semblent confrontés en vis-à-vis à
nos concitoyens que nous connaissons
depuis toujours un qui connaissent une
vraie difficulté
la réponse que l'on pouvait apporter
parfois c'était effectivement ce contrat
aidé qui peuvent permettait de remettre
le pied à l'étrier de quelqu'un qui est
dans notre entourage dans notre
voisinage et ça il faut aussi penser
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les élus se trouve
démuni de cette réponse humaine
immédiate un problème d'une personne
un exemple simple que j'ai en tête c'est
une personne qui a des difficultés
familiales qui sommait abandonné à à
boire qui était en train de plonger
complètement et puis la commune décide
de le prendre et c'est pas toujours
facile de prendre un contre est dit dans
ces cas là parce que le regard des
concitoyens en disant pourquoi celui-ci
plutôt qu'un autre
et puis et puis six mois après je veux
dire cette personne dans un milieu
professionnel reprend pied pied acquis
et puis et puis reconstruit sa vie
aujourd'hui je cette image en tête une
personne qui effectivement on suit son
chemin personnel et professionnel
parce que monsieur ferrat a dit a pas
d'argent pour faire des projets il faut
savoir que la ddt est requis et
donc les subventions qu'ils sont
octroyés par l'état aux communes rurales
elles ont été augmenté de 39% depuis
2014 et ces subventions ne sont pas
toutes utilisées la même chose pour le
faux le fcl qui est pour
l'investissement local enfin les noms
sont barbares c'est ça il ya deux types
de subventions qui ne sont pas utilisés
et j'en prends une troisième qui sont
les contrats leader 1 qui sont des
contrats européens
en france on les utilise 1 6% et c'est
pour l'écossé pour la ruralité
on les utilise à 6% et là il ya vraiment
yabo ya de l'argent derrière possible
parce qu'il ya une grosse lourdeurs
administratives
elsa à une réaction chez de votre côté
dans ce café de la poste
oui je suis désormais avec sylvain
razzano vous faites partie de la cfdt
sylvain quelles sont les conséquences de
cette de ces baisses de dotations de
l'état
alors la première donc je suis
effectivement secrétaire général de la
cfdt départementale au titre des emplois
publics jeu on couvre le champ notamment
de l'emploi public des territoriaux mais
aussi de l'état donc effectivement la
baisse des dotations c'est un refrain
qu'on entend régulièrement de la part
des employeurs publics et
malheureusement les premiers en en
première ligne sont bien sûr ceux qui
rendent le service public c'est à dire
les employés municipaux donc scellé
vraiment eu quelle raison le terrain
c'est eux qui aujourd'hui assure le
service public en local et notamment
dans les petites mairies alors on peut
parler des atsem dans les écoles donc et
on peut parler également de des agents
communaux qui sont polyvalents et qui
les gère l'ensemble des emplois
techniques de la commune ça se traduit
comment concrète elle concrètement
aujourd'hui quand on parle de dotation
de baisses de dotations de
fonctionnement le fonctionnement c'est
essentiellement les emplois et
malheureusement en emploi des
contractuels et aujourd'hui c'est les
contractuels qui sont les premiers visés
on a entendu dans la politique du
gouvernement actuel
une favori de favoriser l'emploi
contractuel
aujourd'hui on crée de la misère
aujourd'hui au niveau des emplois
publics
et ça c'est une catastrophe pour notre
service public
quels sont les remontées que vous avez
du terrain eh bien écoutez les remontées
du terrain c'est surtout des administrés
qui en face non plus le service public
alors à tort on est en train aujourd'hui
de monter le service public contre le
service le service enfin le privé et
force est de constater que les
administrés disent oui faut moins de
fonctionnaires mais est ce qu'ils sont
prêts à assumer le fait qu'on supprime
de la santé dans les services ruraux
aujourd'hui si on parle de la santé par
exemple je vous donne juste un exemple
comme ça aujourd'hui si on supprime les
emplois dans l'est dans le hot dans le
haut côte-d'or a par exemple eh bien
finalement quand un service public se
ferme
nous n'avons même pas de priver à côté
c'est à dire qu'il faut en moyenne 8
kilomètres pour trouver un médecin pour
un administré donc dans des zones de
ruralité où les personnels ou les
administrés sont des personnes plutôt
âgées est donc pour eux ça pose un
véritable souci de service public
merci beaucoup merci à la merci à ceux
qui sont tout autour de nous de réagir
aux propos de nos invités parmi les
invités qui n'ont pas encore pris la
parole prenez votre micro louis
gentilhomme ancien maire de saint seine
sur vingeanne c'est en côte d'or un peu
plus de 400 habitants à qui je dis pas
de bêtises elles vont naître en plus mr
on a entendu votre ancien premier
adjoint tout à l'heure vous n'êtes plus
mer depuis le mois de janvier
depuis le 1er janvier et je voulais
évoquer avec vous parce qu'une des
raisons il ya toutes celles qu'on a déjà
évoqué évidemment et sur lesquels vous
pouvez revenir bien sûr mais mais quand
je vous ai appelé la première chose pour
vous inviter à cette émission la
première chose que j'ai ressenti c'est
une forme de lourdeurs administratives à
incroyable c'est à dire que le moine des
efforts la moindre des choses que vous
voulez mettre en place et même si des
fois on peut trouver des crédits mais à
quel prix il faut des tonnes des tonnes
des tonnes d'investissement et puis de
temps et puis aussi peut-être jambes a
beaucoup d'argent et peut-être aussi
vous n'êtes pas assez formés pour
affronter tout ça je pense que la
formation on la trouve sur le terrain ça
c'est clair mais par contre
les problèmes qu'on rencontre avec
l'administration vous parliez tout à
l'heure des subventions il faut dire
aussi qu'à chaque fois que nous
demandons des subventions on nous
demande de faire un schéma de alors
qu'on l'a fait ces faits main que rien
n'a été entrepris
donc il est toujours le même mais on
nous demande de renault de nouveau de
prendre un bureau d'études pour alors
moi je refuse de dépenser de l'argent
inutilement parce que si on me donne des
10000 euros dimension aux gens dépensent
déjà 9000 pour le dossier à faire avec
la personne chargée de ces dossiers on
n'avait plus d'argent pour le reste via
aucune utilité de faire les travaux
c'était le cas je vais vous dire avec le
département jeanneret je pouvais avoir
une d une subvention de 10000 euros pour
mettre des ballons dans viens village
pour le 10000 euros
on me demandait un pataquès pas possible
donc l'étude que j'allais faire faire
par le par le bureau d'études me coûtait
plus faire que l'avion alors vous avez
préféré jeter l'épongé plutôt que de
décevoir vos administrés c'est ça
finalement
je suis j'en avais surtout ras-le-bol de
ne pas être entendus d'écouté oui vous
avez même écrit alors j'écris j'ai
envoyé ma lettre de démission à monsieur
macro qui m'a personnellement répondre
j'apprécie ce en quoi ils prendront le
temps de répondre oui oui oui oui
par contre c'est pas le cas très souvent
des ministres qui nous disent ah ben oui
on va donner le problème at-elle
est-elle dayraut et puis on vous donnera
une réponse qu'on n'a jamais patrice
joly vous voulez réagir à ce qui était
dit cette lourdeur administrative ses
difficultés
qu'évoque louis gentilhomme c'est quand
même la réalité de beaucoup de maires et
c'est d'ailleurs la première raison pour
laquelle il jette l'épongé souvent c'est
la première qui le site
quand on parle de leur démission il ya
la réalité des normes et des langues non
adaptés à la réalité des problèmes posés
théron n'est pas content en tout cas moi
je suis pas contre les normes les normes
c'est le droit le droit c'est ce qui
protège le faible et donc faut être très
attentif à ce qu'on dit mais il ya des
normes qui ne sont pas proportionnés la
réalité du risque et lee a surtout
aujourd'hui les services de l'état qui
n'accompagne plus les collectivités
locales qu'il ya encore quelques années
il y avait des services un peu
structurée dans les sous préfectures qui
a porté sur le plan juridique des
conseils il avait les d'aider à les dde
qui accompagnait ce qui fait que les
projets aboutissent est il était partagé
entre le maître d'oeuvre c'est à dire la
collectivité la commune et/ou syndicats
ou autre et puis les services de l'état
et on arrivait ensemble un projet qui
était viable et qui pouvaient être mises
en oeuvre
deuxième élément donc c'est une dinde
est une des difficultés est
effectivement pour les pour les
collectivités la deuxième c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'ingénierie c'est à dire la
capacité à monter des dossiers et c'est
vrai que la diminution aujourd'hui des
moyens donnés aux collectivités je pense
en particulier aux que notre commune
fait qu'elle ne dispose pas de
l'ingénierie sur le capacité à avoir du
personnel susceptible de dd à monter les
dossiers qui effectivement parfois sont
d'une exigence qui là aussi est
disproportionnée on gère de l'argent
public
il est logique il y à des procédures
qu'il ya des cards mais on a aujourd'hui
parfois alors en particulier s'agissant
des fonds européens ou là on as eu de
véritable usine à gaz et il faut qu'on
puisse alléger
la prochaine procédure allégée ces
modalités de sollicitations des fins ils
apprennent sur le tas les maires vous
vous avez appris sur le tas comment on
n'apprend pas à gérer tous ces dossiers
toute cette lourdeur administrative y a
pas d'école pour ça
non il n'ya pas il n'y a pas d'école
mais c'est vrai que là il ya une
tendance vers plus de technocratie plus
d'un générique et qui est pas toujours
nécessaire vous avez demandé dans des
communes rurales on veut refaire moi
c'est le cas dans ma commune on veut
aménager la place du village mais bon on
peut faire des choses très simplement
vous avez des compétences parfois au
sein d'un conseil municipal vous avez
des gens qui sont capables de faire un
plan de la dudh du bourg et puis de
d'aller voir ensuite la direction des
routes là pour se mettre d'accord vont
sur les bonnes des limitations
il y avait d'ailleurs remarque qu'on
peut faire il y avait tout un tout un
bénévolat tout un bénévolat qui fait
économiser de l'argent à l'état tout un
bénévolat qui est qui était exercée dans
l'est dans les communes rurales et qui
disparaît quand avec ces transferts de
compétences on parlait des eaux et
d'assainissement tout à l'heure et vous
nous disiez qu'il faut qu' effectivement
et faire ça bien mais c'était c'était
très bien gérer l'eau et
l'assainissement était très bien géré
vous aviez des gens qui le matin à les
réparer quand il y avait une défaillance
à la lagune c'était pas ça y est
municipal qu'il qu'il le faisait parfois
de moins en moins vrai aujourd'hui vous
appelez un service technique à distance
qui va commencer par envoyer quelqu'un
pour faire un diagnostic ensuite on va
voir quelle entreprise on peut faire
intervenir
ça coûte plus cher et ça ça coûte cher
et ça sera pas forcément ça prend du
temps ça coûte plus cher ça sera ça sera
pas forcément mieux gérer du tout hein
elle a besoin à côté de vous il ya aussi
quelqu'un qui veut réagir sur le champ
ses questions de lourdeurs
administratives dans les petites
communes oui patricia gourmand vous êtes
élu depuis 1995 qu'est-ce que vous
inspire le débat
bon c'est vrai que ça fait quatre
mandats donc l'usure non gelée pas parce
que j'aime j'aime ce que je fais c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose
une mission de maire c'est une des plus
belles missions ce qui est
ce qui est lourd aujourd'hui c'est que
sais je vais pas dire chaque matin mais
presque chaque matin nous avons des
changements de lois
quand on voit simplement
l'assainissement depuis je veux dire
quelques quelques années un conte suisse
a quand même par une seule fois on a pu
dire à la main un moment donné on fait
ça c'est pas possible
le lendemain of mauritius est en
revanche ne dit pas je dire donc
aujourd'hui on n'est même pas très très
sûr de ce qui va arriver et je suis
président du syndicat donc je sais ce
que je veux dire ça c'est une première
sur deuxième chose quand on voit les
dématérialisation
dites moi dans une petite commune alors
nous on a de la chance j'ai mille quatre
cents habitants
j'ai une secrétaire donc une dgf qui est
parfaite et je l'en remercie
mais dans une petite commune quand il va
falloir dématérialisée tout ça quand on
voit tout ce qu'il faut acheter les
ordinateurs les formations et tout ce
qui s'ensuit
il ya des communes qui pourront pas le
faire c'est l'instabilité votre
principal problème complètement
on n'est jamais sûr chaque matin comme
je dis il ya quelque chose qui nous
tombe dessus
gentiment mais nous le temps est ce que
c'est une autre façon d'être élu
patricia vinck y avait du recul
ah oui voilà aujourd'hui je dire s'est
il faut être en éveil de tout on éveille
de tout fin je pense que mes collègues
qui regarde mais je pense que c'est ça
en éveil de tout tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps alors
en plus on a quand même à gérer quand
même nos habitants et ça on est élu pour
ça et par eux il faut quand même pas
oublier et c'est vrai que quand je vois
depuis que je suis maire là quand on
avait des finances dit on pouvait quand
même je dire compter sur nos finances
on nous a mis quand même ce qu'on
appelle un speak ce 20 juillet ce que ça
veut dire pour ceux qui connaissent bien
fonds de péréquation ont intéressé à g
bah ça sert à rembourser à aider les
communes qui ne sont pas comme une bonne
gestionnaire
alors ça veut dire en sus non madame de
course je crois que c'est ça ça veut
dire non non non ça veut dire quelque
part
toutes les communes qui ont vraiment
bien géré et qui ont bien géré et j'en
fais partie
on se retrouve avec des sommes à données
énormes et n'ont donc un moment donné on
nous enlève des dotations mais on nous
remet des choses de ce site exemple
aussi pour des communes et les
intercommunalités reçu un tout à ce que
je disais tout à l'heure on avait la ddt
qui nous aidaient sûr je veux dire les
permis de construire intercommunalité
plus de 15000 hommes services communs
qui c'est qui paye
commune voilà donc on fait que ça et
tous les jours et tous les jours et pour
terminer quand on dit par exemple je
veux dire et je vous entends on a la
possibilité d'avoir des subventions
je reprends ce que vous avez dit je dire
fait essayer de faire un dossier je dire
pour l'europe
essayez de faire un effet sont essayés
je vous assure que si vous n'êtes pas ou
si vous n'avez pas le côté administratif
à côté de vous c'est une usine à gaz
donc très compliqué très compliqué ce
qui fait que la plupart du temps et bien
je m'en parlait là toutes les deux tout
à l'heure dans lequel la plupart du
temps on ne fait pas ces demandes
c'est trop compliqué donc et encore je
dis encore chez nous on a quand même
c'est à dire une secrétaire qui sait le
faire mais sinon dans les petites
communes c'est pas possible
merci merci on va laisser répond
violaine de courson rapidement sur ces
points là où il ya juste quelques choses
sur lesquelles je voulais revenir de mes
collègues élus c'est celle sur les
maires ruraux
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de très
important c'est le bénévolat des équipes
municipales rurales va bien on sait très
bien que moi par exemple j'ai rencontré
sur les 343 commune qui constituait ma
circonscription j'en ai rencontré deux
sens et là dessus je leur ai demandée
évaluée à peu près 20 heures et puis
celle de votre conseil pour le tracteur
de macha pour boucher les trous le cid
ça ou le quad vous connaissez donc on a
évalué par un emprunt de communes comme
flavigny sur ozerain qui compte 3 100
habitants ces cent mille euros 1 5000
euros par an ces cent mille euros par an
en fait c'est la machinerie qui nous
manque
l'ingénierie parce que oui il ya une
place on peut la faire soi même je
comprends ce que vous dites tout à fait
il ya des projets comme les projets
européens par exemple qui devant les a
généré plus importantes et les
téléphones européens ils sont pas
bloquées par l'europe un faux pas ils
sont bloqués par la france
c'est en france qu'on se débrouille pas
bien la roumanie elle utilise
complètement c'est ses leaders mais nous
on reste moi c'est donc il faut changer
ça pour qu'on puisse accéder à ces
financements pour les communes rurales
le plus facilement possible
louis gentilhomme a l'air d'acquiescer
oui moi je partage tout à fait l'opinion
qu'elle vient d'émettre
c'est vrai que
des dossiers comme l'europe demande
beaucoup de préparation meilleur vous
aviez emmanuel macron en face de vous
bruit gentilhomme qu'est ce que vous lui
demanderiez au nom de ces maires des
petites communes que vous avez été qu'on
arrête les descriptions de bistrot ah
bah ça tombe mal c'est normal on est
dans un bistrot et qu'on soit efficace
- c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
l'efficacité un sujet il ya une analyse
ensuite et a les moyens mais temps passe
et après il ya l'exécution c'est aussi
simple que ça mais en france on
complique les problèmes jean-françois
farenc parmi les démissions la grande
majorité écrasante majorité sont des
maires de petites communes de moins de
2000 habitants 887 sur 1021 une
démission volontaire recensés alors est
ce que le pouvoir en place
mais le précédent aussi on peut dire
presque est un pouvoir des métropoles
des grandes communes finalement oui je
crois que c'est un processus qui vient
date d'assez loin et je pense que si on
veut arrêter ça il faut il faut faire
confiance
il faut faire confiance aux équipes
communales et puis il faut réfléchir
enfin au rôle de ces équipes communales
là on voit bien que quand il ya des
élections les taux de participation sont
sont plus importants dans les communes
pour élire les équipes municipales que
pour d'autres élections
on aura sans doute aux élections
européennes un taux d'absentéisme qui
sera très important
donc là il ya quelque chose là avec ses
équipes communales qui est très
important pour tout simplement
l'equilibre de la société le maire il
s'occupe du vivre ensemble du vivre
ensemble local le maire et son équipe
municipale s'occupe du vivre ensemble et
donc il faut faire attention quand même
à 20 il faut arrêter parce qu on
désespère avec les transferts de
compétences les baisses de dotations on
désespère et puis et puis les exemples
eau assainissement du mois de juillet
est très malheureux ça veut dire que ça
n'a pas été compris les députés alors je
sais bien que c'était le 31 juillet ont
voté ce dessaisissement de la commune
les communes avaient
la compétence eau assainissement depuis
200 ans donc on les a dessaisi
on les a dessaisi je pense que les
députés ont pas pris le temps de
réfléchir enfin fin juillet à ce qu' il
ya quelques jours les représentants des
régions des maires de france des
départements étaient réunis à marseille
ils ont parlé de mouvement de contre
décentralisation de recentralisation
est ce que tout ça est organisée est ce
que le réduire le prêt le président
macron président des métropoles est en
train de deux tours centralisée et
finalement oublié les territoires ruraux
est ce que c'est votre point de vue le
micro et oui c'est mieux la suite d'un
processus qui est déjà un peu en suisse
considéré que la société sur un meilleur
s'il est organisé en organisation
massifier c'est-à-dire concentration des
entreprises en milieux économiques
concentration les agrandissements des
des institutions locales
on a vu ça c'est une erreur je veux dire
les exemples qui ont été présentés à
l'instant montre qu' on peut être très
efficace très utile et moins coûteux
dans des petites unités et 7 cas dits
commune moi j'avais fait le cas pour
reprendre dit zaher yolaine de courson
lorsque j'étais maire il ya quelques
années je vais essayer d'identifier rien
que le conseil municipal il y avait
c'est sans parler des réunions mais 4 4
équivalents temps plein ça n'était pas
rien si on y ajoute effectivement la
capacité qu'on a à mobiliser le
voisinage ce qu'ils peuvent nous nous
nous aider les gens 9 d'aider des
actions communales c'est très important
aujourd'hui on nous a dit aussi les
intercommunalités vont permettre de
faire des économies d'échelle en a plein
la bouche économies d'échelle ça n'est
pas vrai rêve dont les ventes à venir ce
qui relève de dut technique en quelques
sortes un l'eau l'assainissement même la
voirie la question se pose en plus
lorsque l'on concentre on va pieds et
poings liés vers les grandes entreprises
qui croyez moi s'entendent d'ailleurs
parfois elles ont été condamnées pour
ces procès entente là le seul intérêt
qu'il peut y avoir parfois c'est en
matière de développement une certaine
professionnalisation qu'on ne devrait
pas faire une petite échelle mais ne re
ne fonctionnons selon le système de la
subsidiarité ne confions niveau
supérieur que ce qui ne peut pas été
fait à l'échelle de deux bases c'est
fondamental en plus comme le disait le
collègue
c'est à dire c'est la cellule de base à
celle de base de la république
c'est long on a le sentiment
d'appartenir à une communauté plus
globale qu'a la france violaine de
coursan stars proches qu'on fait
beaucoup à emmanuel macron d'être le
président des grandes villes et des
métropoles s il y à des territoires
oubliés dans notre république
cependant pas du tout enfin moi je ne
crois pas du tout je crois que toutes
les mesures que nous avons votée jusqu'à
présent et tous les nouvelles lois qui
vont être votés pour la pauvreté le plan
santé le plan pour les écoles sa
sacro-sainte autant la ruralité
les rappels et ré plus ça concerne aussi
bien la ruralité les assignés à
résidence
ça concerne autant les résultats les la
ruralité avec les assignés à résidence
dans les villages des gens qui n'ont pas
de famille on a un président et six
intercommunalités je vous préviens comme
il ya là quelques-uns qui tapent dessus
il va peut-être pouvoir se défendre je
voulais dire aussi assez baissé par
rapport à l'histoire de projets parce
que je crois dans les projets de
développement et par exemple
actuellement dans ma circonscription
d'un train de signer on a signé un
contrat de transition écologique avec un
certain nombre avec deux
intercommunalités et c'est des projets
qui viennent du bas c'est pas des
projets qui viennent du haut et là c'est
vraiment dû avoir du cas par cas et
c'est ce genre de projet qu'il faut
qu'on continue à développer dans nos
territoires pour le rendre singulier et
attractif ça ne doit pas venir que du
haut elle a besoin vous n'êtes pas seuls
il ya encore des réactions autour de
vous oui oui les gens écoutent
attentivement et m'interpelle pour
réagir bernard vous vous fait partie
d'une association d'usagers du transport
à leurs territoires oubliés ou pas bien
sûr selon les selon les départements
selon les mêmes dans les départements
les endroits où l'on se trouve on peut
plus ou moins disposer de services de
transport qui permettent tout un chacun
de ceux de se déplacer et c'est
extrêmement vraiment il est évident que
dans une grande ville pour par ici par
exemple dijon ici mais il y en a
d'autres
il est très facile de se déplacer par
les transports
collectif sans avoir forcément besoin de
nourriture qu'on peut ne pas avoir ou ne
pas vouloir avoir par contre quand on
arrive dans un milieu rural c'est
totalement bien sûr totalement différent
on peut avoir la chance de se situer sur
au bord d'une voie ferrée qui fonctionne
toujours bien il y en ait encore
heureusement et qui vous permet de vous
rendre dans la grande ville ou d'aller
d'apprendre panneaux
qui et de services par par autocars mis
en place par le département met en place
par le département mais repris
maintenant par là par la région donc les
régions bourgogne franche comté ici qui
a repris l'ensemble des services du
département
et là c'est là que ça devient plus
compliqué parce que on est aujourd'hui
sur des services qui sont extrêmement
variable d'un département à un autre et
si on est dans le département un
département que je connais bien qui est
celui de la nièvre des spas monsieur
joly on a beaucoup moins de facilités
pour se déplacer par les transports
collectifs par autocar qu'on peut en
avoir
en côte d'or ou en saône et loire où il
existe un très bon de très bons services
de transport malheureusement dans
d'autres départements
la 10e site et la nièvre mais il
yad'autres 1 les services sont fur et à
mesure des années se sont un peu réduits
à peau de chagrin
heureusement il reste des services à la
demande ce qu'on appelle les en jargon
des terres des transports à la demande
qui permettent de se rendre d'un point à
un autre mais qui demande de préparer
son voyage de téléphoner de
l'anticipation
est-ce que vous avez une question pour
nous et quelques calé lors qu'elle est
leur conception
justement du transport collectif en
particulier en zone rurale et très
rurale parce que il est il est évident
que les choses vont devoir évoluer la
reprise par le conseil régional
ça veut dire que les services devraient
plus être à l'identique de ce qu'ils
sont pas ce qu'il devrait y avoir une
certaine réorganisation est ce que c'est
ce que les élus départementaux ou infra
départementaux sont prêts à collaborer
si bien sûr de conserver jal leur
demande à cette réorganisation quiniou
en tant que d'autres nous intéresse
beaucoup
quelle politique et quelle organisation
pour les transports voilà voilà parce
qu'effectivement ça participe de la vie
de ces territoires ruraux et les mères
se sentent aussi un peu démunis face à
ces questions là patrice joly on parlait
de la nièvre c'est bien vous qui êtes
sénateur de la nièvre que vous puissiez
répondre sur cette question des
territoires ruraux oublier les faux en
fait c'est finalement là c'est presque
la france des tgv contre la france des
ter et encore quand il ya des ter nous
disait la question de le sentiment
d'appartenir à la france périphérique
est aujourd'hui une réalité
quelles que soient les actions
effectivement que ce gouvernement
précédent celui ci ont peu peuvent mener
sentiment de ne pas être exactement pris
en compte
au regard de nos besoins mais je me dis
aussi au regard de notre capacité à
faire du développement et à construire
les choses pour port demain
la difficulté sur les la gestion des
services à de très grandes mais chez
ciel c'est que on est nécessairement on
passe par des procédures globale et avec
des grilles d analyse qui sont qui ne
permet pas de prendre en compte et
d'ajuster très précisément la réponse
aux besoins et quand on est dans le
châtillonnais c'est pas la même chose
quand on est dans le besoin dans la
nièvre ça n'est pas la même chose quand
ça m'a aidé
trio du terrain que se prennent les
meilleures décisions c'est pas toujours
vrai mais ça dépend justement il n'ya
pas d'à priori aujourd'hui ray sur un a
priori que tout ce qui est plus grand
plus gros plus massifier le disait
nécessairement permet de mieux
fonctionner les écrans et ça n'est pas
le cas ça se démontre à chaque fois
sortons de cette approche de c2c cadre
d' analyse qui aujourd'hui nous enferme
et nous conduisent à ce que nous ayons
sentiment est effectivement d'être un
peu relayée jean-françois farenc
puisqu'on parle de transport il ya
certains maires au moment de leur
démission qui disent les 80 km heure les
taxes sur le carburant qui augmente le
montant des contrôles techniques qui
augmente mais dans le rural
on ne tient pas vraiment on prend pas
vraiment en compte cette réalité là des
déplacements et puis on nous répond ben
plan vélo sauf que le plan vélo c'est
bien mais dans le rural ça marche pas
forcément dont le plan vélo c'est bien
et je pense que c'est bien plutôt pour
les pour les zones urbaines où quand on
est vraiment à proximité de la ville
parce que bon moi je vois dans les
villages les gens vont quand même
travaillé à 20 ou 30 km en général
quelques-uns travail dans le boue dans
le dans le village mais bon ça s'éteint
c'est un pourcentage très faible s'il ya
40 ans était c'était différent les gens
étaient dans le village et travailler
dans le village donc aujourd'hui ils
font des kilomètres
et effectivement le vélo n'est pas n'est
pas adapté pour aller travailler à
trente kilomètres
et ben ont tous eu tous les actifs ont
ressenti cette limitation à 80 comme
quelque chose d'un peu d'un peu
automatique est un peu là encore d'un
peu systématique alors que ça aurait pu
être plus ciblés et puis bon ça c'est
les actifs mais à deux autres catégories
pour lesquelles le transport est très
important c'est les personnes les
personnages et des personnages seniors
et les jeunes qui ne conduisent plus et
les jeunes nés dans le village et sauver
la vie du village il faut aussi et les
jeunes et aînés et les enfants avec la
question du transport scolaire
ça c'est très important parce que les je
dirais les jeunes familles qui arrivent
dans nos villages dans les deux trois
questions qu'ils posent en arrivant il
ya notamment le transport scolaire
comment est organisé six a pas d'école
dans le village
comment est organisé le transport
scolaire après il pose aussi la question
du du très haut débit ou des choses
comme ça mais le le transport c'est
vital le transport scolaire et ça l'est
aussi pour les personnes âgées qui
notamment les plus âgés qui à 80 ou 90
ans ne vont peut-être plus conduire et
ont besoin par exemple de transport à la
demande
yolaine de courson ces territoires
qu'ils sentent qu'ils décrochent qui
sont un petit peu oublié en quelque
sorte
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez vous la
majorité la république en marge des
manuels macron on vous oublie pas du
tout la loi sur le transport le
sentiment oui c'est pas la perfection
mais c'est pour ça que moi j'aimais
chine à remonter je vois bien je vois
les choses et 10 rebonds la loi pour le
transport ferroviaire
c'est priorité donnée aux transports du
quotidien donc c'est fini le tout tgv
voilà et on ne ferme plus deux petites
lignes et les lignes
peut-être gérer la gestion va être
privatisée
tu vas être des doutes après pour le la
question de la mobilité c'est vrai que
la mobilité ruralité ses clés quoi parce
que on peut on parlait tout à l'heure
déjà assigné à résidence ces gens qui
n'ont pas de permis
donc je pense qu'il faut développer des
plateformes de mobilité sociale et
solidaire qui pourront permettre à tout
un chacun de se déplacer et la loi
l'homme va permettre aussi de mieux
organiser l'autopartage et que même le
que les particuliers soient rémunérés
pour partager leur voiture en dehors de
tous les efforts qui va être fait sur
les autres moyens de transport donc là
dessus je pense qu'on n'est pas oublié
mais c'est vrai que quand on est à la
campagne on n'est pas en ville alors il
ya un peu moins de trois mois et on va
dire alors ça c'est le cas de le dire il
ya une autre catégorie de personnes qui
souffrent de cette situation et puis des
mères qui finalement ne savent plus sur
quel pied danser c'est la question des
écoles donc les parents d'élèves les
instits etc
des fois les classes uniques semaine de
cinq jours semaine de quatre jours elle
a besoin
c'est une question qui est importante et
les maires ont parfois surtout dans les
petites communes mais c'est vrai aussi
pour les grands du mal à gérer cette
cacophonie gouvernementale d'un
gouvernement à l'autre un géorgien
oui à mes côtés isabelle vous faites
partie de la fcpe isabelle il ya
quelques instants beau m'avait dit ça
manque un peu de concret oui parce que
j'ai envie de rebondir sur la question
des mobilités effectivement comme vous
le disiez allée centrale mais nous
qu'est ce qu'on vit sur le au quotidien
qu'est ce que nous disent les parents en
fait des enfants qui vivent dans les
petits villages
ils nous disent que parfois on met
l'enfant à l'école maternelle ailleurs
voir dans le privé et ce qui est pour
nous parents fédération des conseils de
parents d'élèves de l'école publique à
un drame on les met dans le privé parce
que l'école maternelle ne peut pas les
accueillir
on ferme des écoles dans les petits
villages parce qu'on n'a pas assez on
n'a pas assez d'enfants mais ça se joue
à deux trois enfants ou alors on est des
classes surchargées
en fait le choix qu'on a dans ces cas là
c'est de scolariser ses enfants pas dans
les meilleures conditions et pour nous
qui sommes très attachés à l'égalité des
droits à l'accès à l'éducation
là on est dans la justice on est dans la
justice à l'école on est dans la justice
ensuite au collège pour des enfants
au cinéma avoir accès à toute la culture
c'est pas possible on voudrait dans un
petit village et que le bus le coût du
transport doit être supporté par la
commune les moyens sont ouvre en fait
pour garantir cette égalité là et puis
ça continue ça continue comme vous avez
des collégiens la liaison cm2 6e
maintenant c'est un seul système de la
sixième comment faire une analyse
correcte quand vous avez des villages
qui sont très très loin des collèges et
qu'il faut encore payer ce bus et puis
et puis ça ça pèse sur toute la
scolarité parce que quand les enfants
arrivent sera choix d'études
d'orientation celui-ci il pèse parfois
enfin ce qui pèse sur ce choix là c'est
pas l'envi du gamin c'est pas même les
les voix de deux je perds mes mots ce
n'est pas ce qui va leur permettre de
faire avancer le pays s'est passé face à
ce qui passe et comment je fais pour
aller au lycée on a des lycéens dans la
nièvre qui se lève à 5 heures du matin
pour rejoindre lycée de secteur on
s'entende bien et derrière c'est je
choisis mes options en fonction du
transport en fonction de tout ça et si
je veux aller un petit peu plus loin je
dois payer d'internât donc ça pèse tout
la ruralité et le maillage du transport
qui est un point névralgique pèse sur la
scolarité des enfants à l'école de la
république c'est pas possible
et j'en profite juste parce que c'est un
débat citoyen pour faire un appel aussi
à tous nos concitoyens ils sont tous ses
lecteurs de parents d'élèves ils vont
devoir élire leurs représentants
vendredi message est passé
évidemment alors yolaine de courson
inégalités l'école la république c'est
quand même le lieu de l'égalité et c'est
vrai que on a l'impression que nos
territoires ruraux
ils sont à peu délaissé de ce côté-là
aussi parce que forcément c'est plus
contraignant et en même temps les maires
pourront nous dire ces familles cette
jeunesse ses enfants c'est aussi la
vitalité de nos villages oui j'ai tout à
fait d'accord avec tout ce qu'a dit
madame c'est à dire qu'effectivement il
faut que tous les enfants puissent se
déplacer pour aller à l'école le mieux
possible la rue madame c'est que c'est
pas toujours facile
c'est pas toujours facile c'est vrai ben
y'a pas beaucoup de choses très faciles
dans la vie un non mais là on n'est pas
du temps de traverser la rue quand même
vous
les traverses et trottoirs étaient des
caisses contenant du lait comme de
l'autre côté a forcément mais vous savez
qu'il ya la loi va donc obliger les
parents avec leurs enfants à l'école à
partir de l'âge de trois ans donc là
pour exemple pour l'école maternelle
le problème va pu se poser normalement
en termes de commandes jamais bon dans
parce que ça va devenir obligatoire donc
les régions qui ont donc la
responsabilité des transports vont
devoir également organiser les
transports pour ces enfants là
maintenant c'est vrai que ça il va
falloir au niveau de la loi mobilité et
voir tous les moyens dont on pourra que
l'on pourra mettre en oeuvre pour que
tous ces déplacements se fasse le mieux
et qui est pas d enfants qu
effectivement qu'il se lève à 5 heures
du matin pour rejoindre leur collège de
leur lycée de territoire louis
gentilhomme vous écoutiez avec attention
la dame qui représente les parents
d'élèves la wii a parce que je crois que
le problème des parents d'élèves est
très important au niveau de ces gamins
et surtout dans les campagnes où les
gamins se lève à des heures pas
possibles pour rejoindre parce que il ya
des circuits d'autre part le problème du
transport en milieu rural rural pose
problème pour les jeunes parce qu'il
n'ya pas toujours des moyens sportifs
sur le village et ses gamins ne peuvent
pas aller faire du sport dans les
environs que font-ils
eh bien ils utilisent leur mobile est
fond le bazar dont le village avec un
bouton pas possible vous pouvez faire
tout les arrêter que vous voulez
insectes 8 intervient parce que la
gendarmerie l'interview par là et ça
agace profondément ça fait partie de vos
cause d'énervement et des raisons pour
lesquelles vous avez démissionné patrice
joly peut-être pour faire le lien entre
le sujet précédent de celui ci il faut
qu'on soit très attentifs
la réponse par la mobilité ne doit pas
être une réponse à la réduction de et
services de proximité c'est à dire
maintenir les classes où elles sont les
écoles où elles sont les filières où
elles sont parlés d'eux des lycées tout
à l'heure il ya des filières qui ont
fermé sur certains territoires ruraux
tout simplement parce qu'elle est pas un
nombre d'élèves standard mais ces
filières apporter des vraies réponses à
la fois la situation des élèves et des
familles mais également aux
potentialités de développement
économique c'est-à-dire de de trouver un
emploi donc ça c'est très attendu ne pas
se faire piéger par les enjeux de
mobilité qui continue à exiger la
proximité d'un certain nombre de
services
ça veut dire les services publics c'est
le maintien en matière d'éducation des
filières existantes et le développement
sur les territoires ruraux des deux
nouvelles filières c'est vrai au niveau
des lycées donc au du secondaire mais
c'est vrai également au niveau
universitaire parce qu'un média et
madame pour déborder des habitants pour
des nos concitoyens pour des familles se
déplacer un coup et qui peut générer des
freins effectivement à la poursuite
d'études et pas des choix qui sont liées
à des à des conditions ou des envies
personnelles
j'évoquais la question de la semaine de
quatre jours cinq jours quatre jours
avec le changement de gouvernement on
est revenu à l'ancienne méthode ça a
posé des questions sur sur le
périscolaire jean-françois farenc est-ce
que vous avez des maires qui sont
concernés c'est vrai que dans une
petite commune même si dans les grandes
ça a été très compliqué à mettre en
place parfois dans les petits c'est très
difficile de passer de l'un à l'autre et
de dire aux gens on va se réorganiser
parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes moyens
alors sur le périscolaire quand même la
grande majorité des communes et des
intercommunalités et là ont décidé de se
passer de revenir à la semaine de quatre
jours parce que parce que la pression
des familles quand même aller dans ce
dans ce sens là c'est plus simple au
passage d'ailleurs ça redonne quelques
quelques quelques quelques quelques
moyens aux communes puisqu'il ya des
dépenses de qui de toutes les animations
périscolaires qui étaient faites là qui
sont qui vont être moindre du coût et et
vous remercier les gens que vous aviez
cherché pendant des semaines et des mois
pour faire du périscolaire en passant
c'est aussi la difficulté pour les
lillois le problème il est là et on a
parlé tout à l'heure des effectivement
des des contrats aidés c'est le sait
c'est un sujet c'est le même sujet mais
bon les familles et enfin faut bien
partir quand même des familles dans les
dents les oui il faut voir la vie la vie
de quelqu'un d'un actif et compliqué il
faut qu'il dépose ses enfants il faut
qu'il qu'il qui lie à son travail en
général le pareil le soir vous voyez si
vous avez trois quarts d'heure pour
aller déposer en fin ou amener votre
enfant à l'école
ensuite il faut aller à son travail à
nouveau un trajet le soir même chose
donc il faut quand même organiser ça au
lieu et je pense qu'il faut partir dès
qu'il faut partir du besoin d'aider des
familles alors certains maires dans
certaines régions ont choisi de
s'organiser dans en dordogne par exemple
certains pensent même faire la grève des
résultats des élections européennes est
ce que ce sont des méthodes qui vous
semblent de façon à faire prendre
conscience du problème c'est la position
effectivement de l'association des
maires ruraux de france au plan national
ce sera pas la grève des résultats les
les bureaux de vote seront tenues et la
recommandation de l'association des
maires ruraux de france c'est 2
envoyé à la préfecture les résultats le
jour où le la mairie sera ouverte
c'est-à-dire le lundi et parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'état moi je les lui aux
dernières élections demande au maire
d'aller se rendent eux-mêmes
à la gendarmerie donc voyez les machines
on leur enlève des compétences sur ces
enveloppes de très près en tous les cas
ce que feront les maires merci à tous
d'avoir participé à cette émission
d'avoir répondu à ces questions merci à
vous qui est autour de nous et autour
d'elle à d'avoir participé également
merci à sandrine et thierry à leur
équipe de nous avoir accueillis au café
de la poste de velars sur ouche dans un
instant l'actualité régionale suivi 2
dimanche en politique version nationale
francis letellier rochois l'eurodéputé
les républicains nadine morano très bon
dimanche à tous